[Musica]
ciao a tutti
allora prima di tutto parto dicendo che
è un grande piacere essere qui a
mirandola il nostro territorio e anche
di comunicarli di farvi partecipi e del
fatto che facciamo parte di uno dei
territori più importanti a livello
mondiale la motor valley proprio in
questi giorni a modena c'è una
manifestazione importantissima e questo
ci deve rendere fieri perché in giro per
il mondo
la motor valley è paragonabile anche se
con magnitudo un pochino inferiore a
quella che la silicon valley in ogni
parte del mondo dove si va dove noi
andiamo ci chiedono com'è possibile che
in un lembo di terra come l'emilia
romagna veramente piccolo ci possa
essere
ci possono essere così tante aziende che
fanno le più belle vetture super
sportive al mondo e questo è uno dei
delle domande a cui è difficile anche
rispondere diciamo sempre che
probabilmente è perché qui c'è un
tessuto sociale c'è una conoscenza c'è
una passione che non c'è da nessuna
altra parte
e questo non è solo parte della di chi
fa vetture ma di tutto quello che è il
terziario quelli che fanno tantissime
attività e anche in questa regione in
questo in questo lembo di terra abbiamo
eccellenze che sicuramente sono
riconosciute a livello mondiale
ma partiamo da che cosa siamo noi siamo
nati l'azienda che io rappresento è nata
dalla discussione di due imprenditori
della zona dove il loro antagonismo sul
prodotto ha fatto sì di generare quella
che è diventata poi la lamborghini
un'azienda che produce vetture e che è
nata veramente sulla discussione di chi
era più bravo fare una cosa giudicarne
un'altra in questa piccola clip vivi
voglio solo dare un piccolo excursus di
come è nata la vita di come si è voluta
dagli anni 60 e quello che poi noi
abbiamo preso in essere e in carico
[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi cosa importante dire è importante
dire che noi veniamo da un oltre 50 anni
di innovazione cosa significa
innovazione abbiamo sempre lavorato su
dei modelli rendendoli più veloci più
petto più potenti più leggeri che hanno
dato sempre tantissime emozioni ma
rimanendo in un percorso evolutivo
evolutivo quindi di non cambiamenti
epocali
è questo qui sicuramente è un qualche
cosa che non voglio dire ci ha
facilitato perché è sempre difficile ma
ci ha dato un percorso ben definito su
come andarci a muovere oggi con quello
che sta succedendo nel mondo
se ne parlava prima la co2 sta
diventando un problema a livello
mondiale la co2 per dare il la
definizione che ogni tanto ne diamo
proprio per rendere partecipi tutti di
cosa significa e il termometro che ci
dice quando il mondo quanto il mondo si
sta riscaldando quindi più aumenta la
co2 più il mondo si riscalda questo è un
fenomeno fisico dimostrato e quindi
tutto il mondo sta chiedendo di ridurre
le emissioni di co2
per fare questo è chiaro che non si può
continuare a evolvere il prodotto
occorre veramente fare una rivoluzione e
fare una rivoluzione è una cosa
difficilissima a livello industriale
significa cambiare tanti dei paradigmi
che sono parte della nostra conoscenza
però questo è quello che ci aspetta ed è
quello che dobbiamo affrontare perché è
importante una rivoluzione perché perché
noi siamo persone che sono abituati
siamo tutti i nati andando alla pompa
benzina facendo rifornimento caricando
combustibile in 34 minuti avevamo il
pieno in macchina lo trovavamo ovunque
in ogni singolo sul piccolo paese c'era
una due pompe di benzina
ci aspetta un qualche cosa che
sicuramente si muoverà
nell'elettrificazione l'elettrificazione
però è una forma di stoccaggio
dell'energia che è sicuramente un
attimino più complessa è più difficile
trovare delle colonnine di ricarica
quando si va a ricaricare una benzina
che aveva avuto l'esperienza di fare la
ricarica di una bella di una di un
veicolo elettrico
occorrono se la colonnina e veloce 30 40
minuti e noi sappiamo tutti
al giorno d'oggi il tempo è uno dei beni
più importanti è l'unica cosa che non
possiamo comprare quindi sicuramente è
una rivoluzione ma dobbiamo approcciarla
nel modo più corretto in una
supersportiva io il mio mestiere e di
progettare supersportive qual è il
grande la grande sfida e che le batterie
contengono rame piombo elementi
pesantissimi
il peso è il nemico delle supersportive
quello che cerchiamo di vincere
usando materiali super prestazionali
leggeri e quant'altro e in più le
batterie
purtroppo hanno una forma molto regolare
sono dei gran parallelepipedi che tante
volte rischiano di condizionare quello
che è il design di una macchina quello
che è la bellezza di un veicolo per cui
è un qualche cosa che ci si assegna un
compito molto difficile da risolvere per
fare questo
questa è una delle immagini che mi piace
di più dobbiamo cominciare a pensare
sempre in un modo diverso
il coltellino svizzero e quello che ci
fa percepire come in un oggetto solo si
possano mettere dentro tante funzioni
salvando peso salvando quello che noi
chiamiamo packaging ed avendo idee
brillanti su come approcciare un
problema da risolvere
oggi la meccanica è fatta di
trasmissione penso a tutti sappiate che
da un motore esce un albero che poi va
comandare le ruote le fa girare sono
pezzi d'acciaio pesantissimi se pensiamo
alle lettrici cazione dobbiamo
immaginarci il fatto di portare
l'energia con dei cavi anziché con dei
cilindri d'acciaio quindi il che modo
possiamo trovare delle soluzioni che ci
permettano di alleggerire di essere
ancora più flessibili per poter
risolvere uno dei problemi più annosi
però c'è una condizione che fondamentale
noi facciamo macchine vendiamo macchine
siamo desiderati da tutti perché
regaliamo emozioni se non saremo in
grado di regalare emozioni del futuro
brand come il nostro non esisteranno più
e l'emozione è un qualche cosa che è
fatta di sensorialità è fatta di
rispetto di accelerazioni frenate rumore
suono
e questo è una delle cose purtroppo che
non dico è nemica dell'elettrificazione
ma è una delle cose più difficili che
noi dobbiamo combattere ed essere in
grado di risolvere se l'emozione e la
cosa che dobbiamo di sicuro
salvaguardare c'è questa frase di tomasi
di lampedusa nel gattopardo che secondo
me descrive quello che è la grande sfida
che ci attende
se vogliamo che tutto rimanga come era
quindi le stesse emozioni di prima
occorre che tutto cambi bisogna cambiare
tutti i paradigmi dell'automobile
supersportiva in che modo
occorre approcciarli in un modo diverso
mi a tornare nelle scuole perché nelle
scuole perché nelle scuole gli studenti
hanno una capacità di vedere il futuro
completamente diverso dal nostro per
questo noi abbiamo aperto collaborazioni
con lei mighty a boston e abbiamo aperto
laboratori aveva in collaborazione con
stanford
gli abbiamo con le università più
importante italiane politecnico di
milano torino l'università di bologna
in tutto il mondo di andare a cercare
questo tipo di competenza
occorre collaborare con settori che non
facciano parte del nostro mondo ma
abbiano approcci completamente diversi
nel risolvere problematiche tecniche
l'esempio della boeing con cui abbiamo
aperto diversi rapporti di
collaborazione fondamentale materiali
leggeri soluzioni innovative ma anche
con aziende che non hanno nulla a che
fare con l'automobile la calloway fa
mazze da golf
però in questo contesto si sono trovate
soluzioni che riportano il suono
riportano la leggerezza riportano al
trattamento di materiali che non avremmo
mai pensato si potessero fare
e poi bisogna tornare nelle nuove
generazioni perché le nuove generazioni
perché purtroppo chi ha la mia età tende
sempre dire abbiamo sempre fatto così
perché devo fare in un modo diverso
i giovani sono dei provocatori giovani
sono quelli che non hanno una memoria
storica che li obbliga a fare cose come
le facciamo noi
e l'esempio che faccio sempre
l'ingegnere dallara che volete tutti
conoscete fu il primo direttore tecnico
di lamborghini fu il direttore tecnico
di lamborghini a 26 anni quando disegnò
la misura era un bambino se lo
consideriamo con la latitudine che c'è
oggi nel misurare
l'ala l'età questo è importante per cui
in che modo noi appoggiamo il futuro
abbiamo reinventato il modo di fare lo
storage dell'energia usando i telai le
monoscocche abbiamo sviluppato soluzioni
elettriche di powertrain completamente
nuove
mettendo i motori nelle ruote e stiamo
reinventando il suono di un veicolo
elettrico un suono che sia naturale che
sia all'altezza di quello che vogliamo e
ci immaginiamo che possa dare le stesse
emozioni di cui abbiamo parlato prima
in tutto questo noi ci stiamo preparando
noi riteniamo di essere pronti e quello
che è importante che siate anche pronti
voi per sfidare questo nuovo futuro che
ci porterà ad avere una sostenibilità
sicuramente migliore dando le emozioni
che una marchia come il nostro del poter
dare
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]